what is the story of how you came to
program doom
what are some memorable technical
challenges or innovations within that
game
so the path that we went after uh after
wolfenstein got out and we were on this
crazy arc where keen one through three
more success than we thought keen four
through six even more success
wolfenstein even more success so we were
on this this crazy trajectory for things
so actually our first box commercial
project was the commander keane
game but then wolfenstein was going to
have a game called spear of destiny
which was a commercial version 60 new
levels so the rest of the team took the
game engine pretty much as it was and
started working on that we got new
monsters but it's
basically reskins of the things there
and there's a really interesting aspect
about that that i didn't appreciate
until much much later about how
wolfenstein clearly did tap out
its limit about what you want to play
all the levels and a couple of our
license things there was a hard creative
wall that you did not really benefit
much by continuing to beat on it
but
a game like doom and other more modern
games like minecraft or something
there's kind of a touring completeness
level of design freedom that you get in
games that wolfenstein clearly sat on
one side of you know all the creative
people in the world could not go and do
a masterpiece just with the technology
that wolfenstein had wolfenstein could
do wolfenstein but you really couldn't
do something crazy and different but it
didn't take that much more capability to
get to wolfenstein with the freeform
lines and a little bit more artistic
freedom to get to the point where people
still announce new doom levels today all
these years after without having
completely tapped out the creativity how
did you how did you put it touring
complete like complete design space
designs
like you know we have the kind of
computational universality eye on a lot
of things
but yeah there's things where a box can
be too small but above a certain point
you kind of are at the point where
you you really have almost unbounded
creative ability there and doom is the
first time you cross that line yeah
where there were
thousands of doom levels created and
some of them still have something new
and interesting to say to the world
about it is that line
can you introspect what that line was is
in the design space is it something
about the programming
uh capabilities that you were able to
add to the game
so the graphics fidelity was a necessary
part because the block limitations in
wolfenstein uh what we had right there
was uh was not enough the full-scale
blocks although minecraft i really did
show that perhaps blocks uh stacked in
3d and at one quarter the scale of that
or 1 8 in volume is then sufficient to
have all of that but the the wall-sized
blocks that we had in wolfenstein was
too much of a creative limitation you
know we licensed the technology to a few
other teams none of them made you know
too much of a of a dent with that it
just wasn't enough creative ability but
a little bit more whether it was the
variable floors and ceilings and
arbitrary angles in doom or the smaller
foxel blocks in uh in minecraft is then
enough to open it up to to just worlds
and worlds of new capabilities what is
binary space partitioning
so these are one one of the technologies
yeah so jump around a little bit on the
on the story path there yes so while the
team was working on spirit destiny for
wolfenstein yes i am i had we had met
another development team raven software
while we were in wisconsin and um they
were doing they had rpg background and i
i still kind of loved that and i offered
to do a game engine for for them to let
them do a 3d rendered rpg instead of the
like most rpg games were kind of hand
drawn they made it look kind of 3d but
it was done just all with artist work
rather than a real engine
and after wolfenstein this was still a
tile-based world but i added floors and
ceilings and some lighting and the
ability to have some sloped floors in
different areas that was my intermediate
step for a game called shadowcaster
and it had slowed down enough it was not
fast enough to do our type of action
things so that they had the screen
cropped down a little bit so you
couldn't go the full screen with like we
would try to do in wolfenstein i but i
learned a lot i got the floors and
ceilings and lightings and it looked
great they were great artists up there
and it was it was an inspiration for us
to look at some of that stuff
but i had learned enough from that that
i had the plan for i knew faster ways to
do the the lighting and shadowing and i
wanted to do this freeform geometry i
wanted to break out of this tile based
uh
90 degree world limitations
so
we had that was when we got our next
stations and we were working with these
higher powered systems and
i we built an editor that let us draw
kind of arbitrary line segments and i
was working hard to try to make
something that could render this fast
enough
um you know i was pushing myself pretty
hard i
and we were we were at a point where we
could see some things that looked
amazingly cool but it wasn't really fast
enough for the way i was doing it i for
this flexibility it was no longer i
couldn't just raycast into it and i had
these very complex sets of lines and
simple little worlds were okay but the
cool things that we wanted to do just
weren't quite fast enough
and i wound up taking a break at that
point and i did the the port i did two
ports of
our games i
wolfenstein to the uh to the super
nintendo it was i it was a crazy
difficult thing to to do which was an
even slower processor it's like two
point i couple megahertz uh processor
and it had been this whole thing where
we had farmed out the i am
the work and it wasn't it wasn't going
well and i took it back over
and
trying to make it go fast on there where
it really did not have much processing
power the pixels were stretched up
hugely and it's it was pretty ugly when
you looked at it but in the end it did
come out fast enough to play and still
be kind of fun from that but that was
where i started using bsp trees or
binary space partitioning trees it was
one of those things i had to make it
faster there it was a stepping stone
where it was reasonably easy to
understand in the grid world of
wolfenstein where it was all still 90
degree angles i'm
bsp trees were i eased myself into it
with that and it was a big success i am
then when i came back to working on doom
i had this new tool in my toolbox it was
going to be a lot harder with the
arbitrary angles of doom this was where
i really started grappling with epsilon
problems and just you know up until that
point i hadn't really had to deal with
the fact that i am so many numeric
things this almost felt like a betrayal
to me whereas people had told me that i
had mathematicians up on a bit of a
pedestal where
i was people think i'm a math wizard and
i'm not i really everything that i did
was really done with a solid high school
math understanding i you know algebra 2
trigonometry and i'm
that was what got me all the way through
doom and quake and all of that of just
understanding basics of matrices and
knowing it well enough to do something
with it what's the epsilon problems you
ran into so i when you wind up taking a
like a sloped line and you say i'm going
to intersect it with another sloped line
i am then you wind up with something
that's not going to be on these nice
grid boundaries with the wolfenstein
tile maps all you've got is horizontal
and vertical lines looking at it from
above and if you cut one of them it's
just obvious the other one gets cut
exactly at that point but when you have
angled lines you're doing a kind of a
slope intercept problem and you wind up
with rational numbers there where things
that are not going to evenly land on an
integer or even on any fixed point value
that you've got so everything winds up
having to snap to some fixed point value
so the lines slightly change their angle
you wind up if you cut something here
this one's going to bend a little this
way and it's not going to be completely
straight and then you come down to all
these questions of well this one is is
is a point on an angled line you can't
answer that in finite precision unless
you're doing something with actual
rational numbers and later on i did
waste far too much time chasing things
like that how do you do precise
arithmetic with rational numbers and it
always blows up eventually you know
exponentially as you do it so these are
these kind of things they're impossible
with computers so
they're possible again there are paths
to do doing it but you can't fit them
conveniently in any of the numbers you
need to start using big nums and uh and
different factor trackings and different
things so you uh you have to if you have
any elements of ocd and you want to do
something perfectly you're screwed if
you're working with floating point yeah
so so you had to deal with this for the
first time yeah there was there were
lots of challenges there about like okay
they built this cool thing and the way
the bsp trees work is it basically takes
the walls and it carves other walls by
those walls in this clever way that you
can then take all of these fragments and
then you can for sure from any given
point get an ordering of everything in
the world and you can say this goes in
front of this goes in front of this all
the way back to the last thing and
that's super valuable for graphics where
kind of a classic graphics algorithm
would be painter's algorithm you paint
the furthest thing first and then the
next thing and then the next thing and
then it comes up and it's all perfect
for you that's slow because you don't
want to have to have drawn everything
like that but you can also flip it
around and draw the closest thing to you
and then if you're clever about it you
can figure out what you need to draw
that's visible beyond that and that's
what bsp trees allow you to do yeah so
it's combined with a bunch of other
things but it gives you that ordering
it's a clever way of doing things and i
remember i had learned this from i one
of my my graphics bible at the time a
book called foley and van damme and
again it was a different world back
there there was a small integer number
of books and this book that yeah
this book that was of his big fat
college textbook that i had
read through many times i didn't
understand everything in it some of it
wasn't useful to me but they had the
little thing about uh finite orderings
of you draw a little t-shaped thing and
you can say you can you can make a fixed
ahead of time order from this and you
can generalize this with the bsp trees
and and i got a little bit more
information about that it was kind of
fun later while i was working on quake i
got to meet uh bruce naylor who is one
of the original researchers that
developed those technologies uh you know
as for academic literature and that was
kind of fun but i was very much just
finding a tool that can help me solve
what i was doing and i was using it in
this very crude way in a two-dimensional
fashion rather than the general 3d the
epsilon problems got much worse in quake
and three-dimensionals when things angle
in every way but eventually i did sort
out the sort out how to do it reliably
on doom there were still a few edge
cases in doom that were not absolutely
perfect where they they even got
terminologies in the communities like
when you got to something where it was
messed up it was a hall of mirrors
effect because you'd sweep by and it
wouldn't draw something there and you
would just wind up with the leftover
remnants as you flipped between the the
two pages but bsp trees were important
for it but it's again worth noting that
uh after we did doom our major
competition came from um ken silverman
and his build engine which was used for
duke nukem 3d and some of the other
games for 3d realms and he used a
completely different technology nothing
to do with i'm
with bsp trees so there's not just a one
true way of doing things i
there were critical things about to make
any of those games fast you had you had
to separate your drawing into you drew
vertical lines and you drew horizontal
lines just kind of changing exactly what
you would draw with them that was
critical for the technologies uh at that
time and like all the games that were
kind of like that wound up doing
something similar but there were still a
bunch of other decisions that could be
made and we made good enough decisions
on everything on doom we
we brought in multiplayer significantly
and it was our first game that was
designed to be modified by the user
community where we had this whole setup
of our wad files and p-wads and things
that people could could build with tools
that we released to them and they
eventually rewrote to be better than
what we released but they could build
things and you could add it to your game
without destructively modifying it which
is what you had to do in all the early
games you literally hacked the
the data files or the executable before
while doom was set up in this flexible
way so that you could just say run the
normal game with this added on on top
and it would overlay just the things
that you wanted to there
would you say that doom was kind of the
first true 3d game that you created so
no it's still doom would usually be
called a two and a half d game where it
had three dimensional points on it and
this is another one of these kind of
pedantic things that people love to
argue about about what was the first 3d
game i still like i'm like every month
probably i hear from somebody about well
was doom really a 3d game or something i
and
you know i give the the point where
characters had three coordinates so you
had like an x y and z the k damian could
be coming in very high and come you know
and come down towards you uh the walls
had three coordinates on them so on some
sense it's a 3d game engine but it was
not a fully general 3d game engine you
could not i you could not build a
pyramid in doom because you couldn't
make a sloped wall
which was slightly different where in
that previous shadow caster game i
couldn't have vertexes and have a sloped
floor there but the changes that i made
for doom to get higher speed and a
different set of flexibility traded away
that ability but you literally couldn't
make that you could not uh you could
make
different heights of passages but you
could not make a bridge over another
area you could not go over and above it
so it still had some 2d limitations to
it that's more about the building versus
the actual experience because the
experience is
it felt like things would come at you
but again you couldn't look up either i
am right you know you could only pitch
it was four degrees of freedom rather
than six degrees of freedom you did not
have the ability to tilt your head this
way or pitch up and down
you